ist es möglich einen aufzug zu bauen der
bis ins weltall reicht eine fähigkeit
sie uns als mensch hat vielleicht am
weitesten nach vorne gebracht hat ist
dinge ins weltall zu bringen
das hubble-weltraumteleskop indect ferne
galaxien und erdähnliche planeten auf
denen wir eines tages einmal leben
könnten
curiosity fährt für uns auf dem mars
herum und in der internationalen
raumstation leben menschen dauerhaft das
weltall ist erstaunlich aber
weltraumforschung ist auch teuer und
manchmal verdammt gefährlich kein wunder
also dass viele kluge köpfe schon seit
jahrzehnten versuchen den gefährlichsten
und teuersten teil der weltraumforschung
zu revolutionieren
nämlich die art und weise wie wir ins
weltall kommen spacex versucht zum
beispiel raketen wieder verwendbar zu
machen
normalerweise werden viele teile einer
rakete nach dem start up gesprengt und
ins meer fallen gelassen
aber space ex will einen teil ihrer
raketen wieder sicher auf der erde
landen lassen um sie später noch einmal
zu benutzen
allein das könnte raketenstart und damit
die weltraumforschung selber auf ein
zehntel oder sogar ein hundertstel der
heutigen kosten reduzieren aber da sind
wir leider noch nicht bisher sind alle
fest einer raketen landung leider knapp
fehlgeschlagen
und die realität ist möchte man
heutzutage ein kilogramm gewicht ins
weltall befördern kostet das zwischen
4000 und 40.000 euro und das nur die
kosten für den transport was auch immer
man ins all schickt könnte noch viel
teurer sein oder das ergebnis
jahrelanger arbeit wenn so viel auf dem
spiel steht möchte man natürlich
möglichst viel sicherheit
die idee etwas zu bauen das bis ins
weltall reicht gibt es schon lange 1895
hatte ein russischer wissenschaftler
angeblich erstmals die idee für einen
fahrstuhl der bis ins weltall fährt und
ach was die klage machte die idee 1979
mit seinem roman the fountains of
paradise berühmt und so soll der space
elevator funktionieren
zuerst einmal wäre es unmöglich ein
gebäude oder einen turm zu bauen der so
hoch wäre ein gebäude würde entweder
wegen des astronomisch hohen gewichts
einfach im boden versinken oder aber
wenn man im weltall ein gegengewicht
befestigt einfach auseinander reißen
nein wir brauchen ein kabel ein
unglaublich starkes und flexibles kabel
aber dazu später mehr das eine ende
würden wir
an der erde befestigen das andere ende
35.000 kilometer weiter oben am eben
erwähnten gegengewicht dieses gewicht
wird so befestigt dass der schwerpunkt
des kabels genau auf den geostationären
orbit ist das ist die entfernung auf der
zb gps satelliten kreisen und auf der
sie immer exakt über denselben ort auf
der erde schweben
mit anderen worten sie rotiert immer
genauso schnell um die erde wie die erde
um sich selbst an diesem kabel könnte
man dann eine kabine befestigen sie rauf
und runter fährt das ist die idee und
wie ihr euch vorstellen könnt gibt es
extrem viele dinge die die umsetzung
erschweren aber mal eins vorneweg es ist
beim heutigen forschungsstand
physikalisch möglich eine weltraum
aufzug zu bauen und in betrieb zu nehmen
nur bezweifle ich sehr dass das
irgendwann in absehbarer zeit passieren
wird wir werden wahrscheinlich schon
vorher auf dem mars landen bevor wir
einen weltraum aufzubauen
eines der größten probleme des weltraum
aufzugs ist zum beispiel das
gegengewicht das gewicht brauchen wir um
den massen schwerpunkt des kabels zu
geostationären umlaufbahn zu bringen
wäre das nicht der fall und der
schwerpunkt werde zum beispiel tiefer
dann würde sich ein teil des kabels
schneller bewegen als der andere und das
kabel würde auf die erde fallen
gut vorstellen kann man sich das zum
beispiel mit einem hammerwerfer mit
gewicht kann der hammerwerfer sich gut
um sich selbst drehen und der hammer
bleibt immer im selben abstand zum
werfer ohne gewicht allerdings wurde das
seil einfach ohne spannung hinter dem
werfer her flattern
übrigens das nennt sich nicht wie viele
denken zentrifugalkraft zentrifugalkraft
gibt es nicht was wir hier beobachten
ist die trägheit der masse die sich
eigentlich nur geradeaus weiter bewegen
möchte aber von seil in eine kreisbahn
gezwungen wird
das große problem ein gegengewicht ist
naja das gewicht so viele tonnen gewicht
und material von der erde in die
umlaufbahn zu befördern würde so
unglaublich viele ressourcen verbrauchen
dass es den ganzen sinn der aktion schon
wieder zunichte machen würde
wir brauchen also etwas das nicht hier
und auf der erde ist sondern schon da
oben ist etwas das wenig hoch bringen
müssen einen asteroiden zum beispiel die
nasa plant im jahr 2022 eine sonde in
einen asteroiden zu crashen
um zu testen ob diese methode im fall
der fälle ausreichen würde um die erde
vor einer kollision zu beschützen
viele forscher glauben dass wir dazu in
der lage sind asteroiden einzufangen
also in unserer umlaufbahn zu bringen
es dürfte allerdings auch jahre wenn
nicht jahrzehnte dauern
für den richtigen kandidaten gefunden
haben und dann zu uns gebracht haben
haben wir erst einmal das gegengewicht
brauchen wir noch ein kabel ein kabel
das unglaublich stark ist und
unglaubliche kräfte aus hält das
trotzdem biegsam und flexibel ist und
dazu muss es noch ein paar leicht sein
damit es nicht so viel eigengewicht
mitbringt für diese extremen
anforderungen kommt eigentlich nur ein
einziger stoff in frage kohlenstoff
nanoröhren sie sind 100 mal stärker als
stahl und besteht zu einem großteil aus
leerem raum nicht masse sie wären in der
lage die extreme belastung auszuhalten
leider konnten wissenschaftler bis jetzt
erst nanoröhren seile mit einer länge
von maximal einem halben meter
herstellen
aber da kommen wir noch 50 zentimeter
und 35.000 kilometer das spielt ja alles
in derselben liga ein weiteres problem
des weltraum aufzugs ist die
energieversorgung der kabine bei
mindestens 35.000 kilometern entfernung
wird der elektrische widerstand so groß
dass es sich einfach nicht lohnen würde
strom per kabel hoch zu schicken und
obwohl die kabine ungefähr ab der hälfte
des weges von alleine nach oben gedrückt
wird muss irgendwo die energie für die
ersten 15 tausend kilometer dasein
solarzellen sind eine idee würden aber
das eigengewicht der kabine wieder stark
erhöhen weswegen man dann noch mehr
solarzellen braucht und so weiter
deshalb haben manche vielleicht
verrückte forscher vorgeschlagen mini
kernreaktor zu verwenden um die
strahlung auf passagiere zu verringern
müsste man den reaktor zwar an einem
seil mit genügend abstand hinter der
kabine her ziehen aber es könnte
funktionieren mal sehen
zu guter letzt muss man auch noch davon
ausgehen dass herumfliegende gegenstände
im weltall mit dem aufzug kollidieren
könnten um das zu vermeiden könnte man
die station auf der erde auf einem
mobilen bot errichten das dann den
gegenständen ausweichen kann ein
weltraum aufzug ist also physikalisch
möglich aber bis dieses konzept wirklich
umgesetzt wird werden wohl noch
jahrzehnte vergehen falls es überhaupt
umgesetzt wird denn es ist ein
unglaublich teures und schwieriges
unterfangen dass so viele ressourcen
verbrauchen würde dass sie sich sehr
sehr lange einfach nicht rechnen würde
wahrscheinlich gibt es für die
menschheit erst sind über solche dinge
nachzudenken wenn wir schon dabei sind
den mars zu kolonisieren und jährlich
nicht zehn sondern 10.000 menschen ins
all fliegen
und auch die experten sind sich uneinig
was sie klagt findet dass raketen für
weltraumflüge ungefähr so sind wie
balance für die luftfahrt überholt musk
gründer der firma spacex hält den
weltraum aufzug allerdings
für realistisch und setzt lieber auf
seine wiederverwendbaren raketen
aber was denkt ihr dazu ist es sinnvoll
so eine riesige konstruktion zu bauen
wenn ja warum wenn nein warum nicht
schreibt eure meinung unten in die
kommentare vielen dank an basti es eher
für den themenvorschlag wenn ihr auch
eine idee für ein video habt dann
schreibt mir auch gerne unten in die
kommentare ich bin mega gespannt zuhören
was hier so auf dem kanal sehen wollt
welche ideen ihr habt also teilte ideen
mit mir
ansonsten würde ich noch viel spaß mit
meinen anderen videos wenn ihr mir noch
nicht auf social media affolter könnt
ihr das hier unten tun sonst würd ich
sagen bis zum nächsten mal